[Música]
sin incidentes transcurrió la jornada
electoral en Ecuador el Consejo Nacional
electoral reiteró que contará todos los
votos de las elecciones en las que más
de 13 millones de ciudadanos estaban
llamados para elegir autoridades locales
y para votar en un referendo impulsado
por el presidente Guillermo lasso con el
principal argumento de combatir la
inseguridad
ya son al menos 24 los muertos y cerca
de mí los heridos por los incendios
forestales en Chile al tiempo que 10
personas sospechosas de provocar fuegos
fueron detenidas las autoridades
informaron que más de 50 conflagraciones
permanecen activas y las regiones más
afectadas siguen siendo
ñuble bío bío y la araucanía
el gobierno de Perú amplió el estado de
emergencia en cuatro regiones más con
ellos son ya siete las regiones que ven
eliminados los derechos de
inviolabilidad de domicilio libertad de
tránsito libertad de reunión y libertad
y seguridad personales en el marco de
las protestas antigubernamentales que
dejan al menos 59 muertos
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Ecuador allí el Consejo Nacional
electoral reiteró que contará y
respetará todos los votos de las urnas
en las elecciones regionales en medio de
la preocupación ciudadana por la demora
de la entrega de resultados la
participación en los comicios superó el
80 por ciento más de 13 millones de
ciudadanos estaban llamados a votar
sobre ocho propuestas para modificar la
constitución del país en un referendo
que ha sido defendido por el gobierno de
Guillermo lasso como un paso hacia la
lucha de la inseguridad que vive el país
escuchemos al cine
es importante mencionar que el
procesamiento y la difusión de
resultados no se detendrá sino hasta
obtener el cien por ciento de las actas
válidas es decir las juntas provinciales
electorales así como los miembros de las
juntas receptoras del voto Siguen con su
trabajo hasta concluir al 100%
tengan la certeza que el Consejo
Nacional electoral respetará cada uno de
los votos expresados por los
Ecuatorianos en las urnas
Cómo avanzábamos la inseguridad ha sido
el argumento clave de Guillermo lasso
para defender el voto a favor de las
reformas constitucionales en el
siguiente informe Manuela Canon nos da
más detalles sobre la situación de
violencia en el país y las medidas que
plantea El Ejecutivo
la inseguridad en el centro del
referendo de Ecuador este domingo el
país fue a las urnas en sus elecciones
regionales un acontecimiento en el que
también decidieronse aprobar o no una
serie de modificaciones a la
Constitución
una votación que llega después de que
Ecuador viviera uno de sus años más
críticos en términos de violencia de
diferentes tipos en 2022 Ecuador
registró unas 4.550 muertes violentas
82,5 más que en 2021 y su registro más
alto desde 1990 así el gobierno de
Guillermo lasso ha promocionado y
alentado a votar a favor de las
modificaciones asegurando que se
encaminarán a revertir dicha situación
la primera pregunta con la que se
encontraron los Ecuatorianos fue está
usted de acuerdo con permitir la
extradición de Ecuatorianos que hayan
cometido delitos relacionados con el
crimen organizado transnacional
según el gobierno la extradición hasta
el momento prohibida por la Carta Magna
del país ayudará a desmantelar las
bandas de crimen organizado y también
tendrá una función disuasiva una
justificación que ha generado críticas
de varios sectores que señalan que no es
suficiente para luchar contra las
inseguridades del país y que hacen falta
medidas profundas contra la pobreza y la
desigualdad al mismo tiempo los
Ecuatorianos votaron sobre la autonomía
de la fiscalía general del estado una
propuesta que ha sido defendida por
lasso quien señala que con mayor
Independencia esta podrá afrontar de
manera más oportuna los casos de
delincuencia en 2022 el gobierno
ecuatoriano optó por decretar el estado
de emergencia en varias regiones del
país debido a un repunte de la violencia
sobre todo en las cárceles
terminando el año como uno de los países
en donde los ciudadanos se sienten más
inseguros de la región según
y pasamos a Chile donde los incendios en
el centro del país han dejado al menos
24 muertos se ha restado a diez
sospechosos de provocar los fuegos la
otra causa de esta situación junto a las
altas temperaturas en una ola de calor
que no da indicios de llegar a su fin
Alba Santana tiene los detalles
entre llamas así se encuentra el centro
sur de chile donde hay más de 260 focos
de incendios 80 de ellos en activo que
ya han arrasado miles de hectáreas han
dañado centenares de viviendas y han
dejado varios muertos entre ellos a
miembros del equipo de bomberos y
civiles y una decena de detenidos
sospechosos de provocar los fuegos algo
que ha obligado al país a pedir ayuda
internacional se ha hecho a través de la
cancillería una solicitud de apoyo
internacional se han tomado ya contacto
con varios gobiernos para reforzar las
gestiones estos contactos están haciendo
con varios países de la región Brasil
Argentina Uruguay los incendios se
concentran en las regiones de ñuble y
biobío que están bajo estado de
excepción por catástrofe y también en
maule y la araucanía una situación que
obligó al presidente Gabriel a boric a
cancelar sus vacaciones y trasladarse a
la zona
decirle de que chile entero llora con
ustedes hoy día y también mediante este
momento duro
agradecerle Eternamente a bomberos a las
bomberas por el tremendo sacrificio que
están haciendo
las alertas rojas y las órdenes de
evacuación han obligado a muchos a
buscar refugio en albergues ya que las
llamas han dejado a muchos sin casa y
han forzado la evacuación de municipios
enteros terrible porque esfuerzo de año
de mi hermano de 2017 que no veíamos
algo así
el vecinos los vecinos están sacando
pocas cosas y uno y llega la ayuda pero
uno ve que parece que no fuera
suficiente lo único que quiere que
llegue agua que el helicóptero que
llegue luego de conaf que llegue todo el
mundo y chile está en medio de una ola
de calor a principal causa de los
incendios en los últimos días las
temperaturas en la zona han rozado los
40 grados celsius y se esperan nuevas
máximas para el próximo martes
el gobierno de Perú amplió el estado de
emergencia en cuatro regiones más a
causa de las protestas
antigubernamentales que en varias
ocasiones han terminado en actos
violentos y dejan al menos 59 muertos
los departamentos de madre de Dios
Apurímac Arequipa y moquegua se unieron
a cusco puno y tacna los siete en
emergencia por 60 días Lo que significa
que en ese periodo se eliminan los
derechos de inviolabilidad de domicilio
libertad de tránsito libertad de reunión
y libertad y seguridad personales además
en puno habrá toque de queda nocturno
Manuela Cano no se explican al siguiente
informe las razones de la región andina
del país para salir a protestar
desde los Andes brutaleira en Perú en
ciudades como cusco en el sur del país
suramericano los habitantes denuncian la
falta de oportunidades en dicha Región
del país
unas desigualdades que explican en parte
las masivas manifestaciones que han
recorrido el territorio peruano desde
diciembre nosotros sentimos que
desprecian hay un centralismo fuerte
como en la Colonia Lima sigue siendo la
capital política económica y
administrativa del país Entonces
nosotros nos sentimos indignados frente
a eso aseguran que la capital se lleva
gran parte de los recursos
gubernamentales profundizando un enorme
brecha que ha generado el hartazgo en
una buena parte de la población
apareciera que hay un país que se llama
lima y otro país que es el resto del
Perú
Precisamente es desde el sur donde miles
de manifestantes han iniciado su camino
hacia lima para hacer escuchar sus voces
desde la periferia a la capital unas
movilizaciones que según Julio oliviera
antropólogo denuncian el olvido de la
zona andina de Perú jamás invirtieron
en los cuenta que los Andes que todas
las Sierra es la que mantiene a la
capital del Perú
en los campos del país también se
sienten inconformismo Rubén García que
ha dedicado su vida entera a trabajar la
tierra dice sentirse invisible para el
estado y sus instituciones por ejemplo
nosotros cuando nos enfermamos Así vamos
al hospital y uno tiene que gastar su
dinero no hay ningún apoyo a pesar de
ser una de las principales zonas
turísticas del país escondiendo
maravillas como Machu Picchu gran parte
de los habitantes andinos aseguran que
sus ingresos no se ven reflejados en su
día a día un reclamo que seguirá sonando
en las calles la mariposa Monarca
especie en peligro de extinción empezó a
resurgir en California esto luego que su
eclosión se retrasará por las duras
tormentas en el estado estadounidense un
acontecimiento esperanzador para quienes
cuidan esta especie que estuvo a punto
de desaparecer hace tres años pese a
ello los expertos temen que esta tardía
eclosión sea perjudicial para ellas los
voluntarios han contado más de 330 mil
mariposas la mayor cifra de los últimos
seis años
y en la ciudad de Los Ángeles se llevó a
cabo la edición número 65 de los premios
Grammy A lo mejor de la música y la
cantante estadounidense Beyoncé hizo
historia y se convirtió en la artista
con más galardones al superar los 31 que
recibió el director de Orquesta húngaro
Georg solty por su álbum rennes sans en
representación Latina el cantante
puertorriqueño Bad Bunny se destacó al
hacer el acto de apertura de la
ceremonia
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
a France 24
[Música]